do you think that inventing the pillow
was an error then socially I think no
I'm personally grateful for the fact
that my life is not entirely dominated
by childbearing which it would have been
in a previous era I'm not going to
expect to have 10 children and to
suspend my whole life either pregnant or
postpartum I think it's more that we
haven't really negotiated with the
social consequences that's the sort of
conversation that I'm trying to initiate
so often you get the popular Narrative
of feminist history basically sees it as
being driven by particularly inspiring
feminists who just kind of give really
strong arguments and everyone's
persuaded in this this is what gives us
the vote this is what gives us access to
professions I don't think that's true I
mean clearly there have been some very
impressive feminists historically yeah
you said the washing machine helped
liberate women more than any feminist
did yeah I think Jordan Peterson has
said the same thing he's completely
right there's all sorts of Technologies
which make it possible for women to have
lives outside of their home